[Music]
so welcome to session number 24 in the
worlds of speculative fiction series
this time we're looking at Fritz
supposed to be pronounced LIBOR but
almost everybody I know says Lieber so
I'm gonna say Lieber because that's what
I've spent my entire life to Fritz
Leiber and his we're looking
specifically at his father to the great
monster stories which are set in this
you know fantasy world new Han and the
city of LaunchBar and I'll talk a bit
about you know this this narrative world
as usual I picked you know some
philosophical themes and one of the
handouts is connected directly to that
first Stevens was going to be just
talking about swords and sorcery itself
which is the genre not only of these
works but Lieber played a major role in
creating that genre so we'll talk a bit
about that the handout is about
friendship and these two guys fought in
the great monster are sort of like and
you know there's this literature of
friendship like throughout the ages
these people who are connected with each
other these two are like that the third
theme I want to talk about is what
struggling to figure out what I want to
call it and so now I came up with a
formulation the ethics of roguery you
know in a road be a good guy or are they
are these really bad guys that are sort
of anti-heroes dressed up as good guys
and so that's an open question I also
want to talk about you know you know
where women fit into the the story and
how how Lieber depicts them and then
there's the other thing was about the
gods and and this is cosmos that he
creates and the weird funny ways that
the gods get depicted which is not very
reverent at all so so I you know as
usually I created a kind of
in timeline about about his long life
you know he died in 1992 is 82 years old
lived a good portion of it as a married
person and then you know was alone
living in a small apartment writing away
for a good portion of it as well and I
put the stories that fit into this
series in in dark so you can see you
know where they fit in with this I
should mention that all of the except
for one novel one actual novel all of
the books in this series are collections
of stories and sometimes they can be
very short stories like maybe 5 10 pages
sometimes they're quite long but they're
all they're all stories and they were
originally published for the most part
in these pulps that we've talked about a
lot and Lieber probably made a lot of
money looking at for these pulp
magazines because he contributed so much
to it I didn't put all of the stuff that
he wrote in here because there's like
you know 15 collections of short stories
and and you know I just wanted to
concentrate on this stuff so I put those
in there I get into Lieber when I was
young in two ways one was through
actually reading stories that he'd
written many of which were not from from
this set but were you know like in the
science-fiction Hall of Fame or things
like that and the other was for playing
D&D Dungeons & Dragons the leaper is
kind of unique in that he was so
important to Gary Gygax or Gygax however
it's pronounced that he was actually
able to lease his characters to TSR and
they became part of the whole mythos
yeah and I mean how many other people
can you say that about I mean if you
read the books that that used to like be
the core of D&D I
what it is now because I haven't played
it for decades but you know you had like
this Dungeon Master's guide and he was
giving you advice about how to create
worlds and stuff like that and he
sometimes say stuff like what was
looking at what Fritz Leiber does so you
know he was clearly very impressed with
them and I think you know Lieber I mean
he had massive cultural influence but I
think that sort of amplified it in a way
he also started a few movies believe it
or not in roles that were uncredited his
parents reactors and of his dad started
some movies and somehow got Gottfredson
to it and so he was in some some early
movies he didn't really take it very
seriously never made a career out of it
or anything like that you know I don't
walk in I should have written them down
but there wasn't anything that rang a
bell with me you know but I am NOT a
very good good movies guy in that way so
let's let's talk about his life so born
in Chicago he'll he'll live in Chicago
for a lot of his life the other places
that he tends to live are Los Angeles
and San Francisco and you could say that
most of his life is kind of you know in
the in that triangle it would be a very
when they call it you know the scalene
is it you know very long triangle and I
should mention he also did live in New
York for a short period so he is born to
two actors people who are actually
professional actors making a living
doing that sort of work in Chicago when
he's 18 he actually tours with his
parents Shakespeare Company and after
that he enrolls at University of Chicago
very bright guy so he has no problem
with that he graduates with honors he
actually didn't get a BA
he got a bachelor's in philosophy degree
a B fill or B pH or something like that
and he he goes off he thinks he might
have some sort of calling so he goes off
to New York
and he studies that in episcopalian
seminary for a very short time less than
a year at a general Theological Seminary
leaves that comes back to the University
of Chicago starts graduate work never
finishes it and instead he starts
working with his parents again doing you
know various odd jobs and and and
filling in and he also starts writing
stories and not long after that he's
going to marry his first wife jonquil
Stevens and he begins a correspondence
with somebody who's really important in
his early work and that's HP Lovecraft
this unfortunately is about a year
before Lovecraft dies but there is a
correspondence between the two of them
and a lot of Leber's early work is not
just in the horror genre but also
Lovecraftian you know sort of like you
know you've got to you've got to
learning from other people you know a
lot of writers their early stuff you can
clearly see the influences of other
people so Lovecraft was a major
influence he manages to get work as a
writer for the standard America
encyclopedia that's going to continue on
until he leaves travels to California
and becomes an instructor at Occidental
College meanwhile his son is born the
only child that they're going to have
when the war comes he leaves his nice
position at the University after the
years finished to contribute to the war
effort it becomes a quality inspector at
Douglas Aircraft you might say well why
didn't he just you know go off and fight
well you know look look at the years
he'd have been in his early 30s had a
wife and kid so you know a lot of people
went and witnessed her working in
factories or things like that for for
the war and he did it precisely because
he he thought that
system fascism was so important there
might have there's a little side note
there might have also been a bit of
worries about being German involved as
well you know in World War one we often
forget just how how many Germans there
were here in the United States you know
at one time it was about 10% of the
population of the United States is
German and during World War one there
actually was a German plot to try to get
you know Mexico to come in and all sorts
of things like that the German
ambassador got held and all sorts of
crazy stuff was going on so there was a
lot of the anti-german sentiment and
this guy unfortunately his name is fritz
so you know that's the the name for
Germans right or that or Herman right
Herman the German and so he was kind of
sensitive about that and then in a world
war two I think he might have felt that
he needed to contribute he stressed or
something he actually wrote he says
there's a lot of a name I'm forever
having to explain that it's pronounced
LIBOR not Lieber and correspondingly
spelled you know II I not ie
and then he said that you know Fritz was
was also a problematic mainly the
teachers and friends who wouldn't accept
that that somebody would would be a
patriotic American with a name like that
interestingly his paternal grandfather
was a German immigrant and had served on
the Union side in the Civil War and his
mother's American roots could be traced
back to the revolution so he had says it
sort of bona fides but there may have
been some sensitivity about that in any
case he he's there when the war ends
they they moved back to Chicago and he
becomes an editor of science digest and
he by now he's already writing his first
major book is is really a piece of
horror Conger wife which is about a wife
who who happens to be a witch and
you know then some of the other things
are sci-fi or fantasy then he's you know
we've talked about george RR martin
before and martin i think i had a one of
these handouts martin was saying
something like ah you know a fantasy
horror sci-fi it's pretty much all the
same thing you just like put ray guns in
the hands of the sci-fi people and
swords the other then set it him you
know some eldritch castle if it's more
something like that and I think Lieber
has that kind of kind of you know
facility of moving between genres in the
same way Harlan Ellison who's somebody
who Lieber influenced quite a bit I
think would be another person who you
could say the same thing about he can
move between these different genres so
now he also I should mention there this
is kind of this is something that does
affect his life you notice that in 1957
he begins participating in alcoholic
UNAM Alcoholics Anonymous you do that
because you're an alcoholic and it
really presented a lot of problems for
him
it's you know he gets it under control
but then later on when his wife dies he
really goes to pot and not only does he
start drinking again but he starts using
some drugs creates some financial
setbacks for him Harlan Ellison writes
at one point about finding Lieber in
this this tiny little apartment with you
know books and crap all around you know
hammering away on a cheap typewriter and
being like what you know what the hell's
going on here and it wasn't hard because
of his his addictions you know it's you
read the stuff that he wrote and it's so
as literature so erudite and so well put
together and you think wow what would
this guy have accomplished if he hadn't
had
and those challenges going on you notice
he's already by the 50s starting to get
recognized he's gonna win quite a few
awards be a guest of honor get you know
inducted into all sorts of things
finally put some of those and one of the
really cool things and I haven't been
able to track down the actual year for
this because there's another guy L
Sprague to come who we're gonna look at
later on who also is a member of
founding member of this the that's
called saga the swordsmen and sorcerers
Guild of America this was a group of
writers who got together very select the
sort of big names in swords and sorcery
fantasy and they would like get together
and drink and you know hang out and tell
their stories sort of like you know what
was the name of the Inklings right then
that Tolkien and Lewis and some of the
other people had over there in England
this was sort of like that and they
would induct other people later on you
know they bring in new blood so that's
that's you know part of what's going on
eventually like I said his wife dies he
moves to San Francisco and starts
drinking again and you know things go on
he keeps producing stuff he's quite a
productive author even writes a play at
one point he wins not only awards in
science fiction and fantasy but also
horror awards at the Brahm Stoker award
and then the year that he actually dies
he wasn't in very good health anyway he
marries Margot Skinner who was a close
friend of his and then you know not long
afterwards dies of a stroke
82 you know that's pretty good for
anybody I think and so talk about the
font and the gray mouser thing so the
first the first book that's published is
to sought adventure but he'd been
writing this stuff
for hand and there's there's actually an
interesting story about this so he had a
friend called Harry Otto Fisher and
Fisher it was a guess from what Lieber
says they were sort of like fogger than
the great Mouser those two guys together
and his friend Harry had sketched them
out in a letter and he wrote in this
letter for all do fear the one named the
green Mouser he walks with swagger
amongst the Bravo's though he's but the
stature of a child so the Mouser is
modeled on Fisher and then Lieber is
supposed to be this you know bigger
brawny er barbarian guy and so it wasn't
it wasn't his own character he really
gets these from somebody else and takes
them over and then builds them into just
story after story after story so this is
this is an omnibus called the three of
swords that has the first three books in
that series in it and then there's four
more so it gives you an idea of just how
much stuff just so much meat there is
right and I want all of them at one
point of time when I was a kid and then
rereading them for this had recently
read just a few years back swords and
ice magic which is the last one where
they're like middle aged settling down
with these these women that they're not
sure whether they're going to marry or
not still having adventures but you know
kind of getting sedate having kids and
and rereading these these early things
he's just such a great writer I you know
I remember enjoying this stuff before
but looking at it very carefully Lieber
has this amazing facility to range from
like writing about a fight scene which
is its own kind of writing
- you know witty dialogue between these
these two guys or other people -
depicting what's going on - writing
stuff that's like just very you know
very well written smut - you know
speculations about the gods and you go
back and forth from one to the next you
know easily and nobody does like his
writing some people said like I don't
know how do you want a Hugo Award for
this it's it's you know boring
I don't find it boring at all I thought
it was actually quite quite good and you
can see how all these other swords and
sorcery people are influenced by him you
can see how so
when you set about the acting good and
there's something really interesting
that I found but I wanted to ask you so
the swords and sorcery stuff was not
very distinct for him from like more
kind of sci-fi traditional like monsters
from the deep did he do a lot of that
kind of writing I wrote a lot of work
okay yeah because do you want to know
what I found out yeah yeah so there's
another actor named fritz leiber who did
a lot of classical like she experienced
yeah right that's not him but his
parents had lived Shakespearean company
well yeah but this guy was born close
enough that he was wearing 1898 so it
was someone else with a similar name and
they're smushed together and IMDB I just
wanted to say that in there one decides
to look it up but so he acted in
equinoxes as dr. arthur Waterman which
was a sci-fi film from the 70s okay for
friends are attacked by a demon like
while picnicking and then he was in
something and then considering a code
the Bermuda Triangle but here's what's
really fascinating so in 1944 which is
only a year after he published the
conjure eyes oh yes turned into weird
woman with yeah with lon chaney yeah
which is then remade twice yeah one says
burn witch burn in 62 and then a second
as witches brew in 1980 and then also
has its own episode in a TV series
called moment of fear from the 60s okay
like the twilights because Andrew White
was actually called conjurer - it was
episode two and yeah I mean the people
that are in this er it's fascinating
because Lana Turner was in one of the
remains well I think was that in burn
witch burn okay no that's that's Janet
Blair but yeah Lana Turner was I think
in the witch's brew remake yeah with
Teri Garr interestingly enough from 1980
but then he also wrote episodes for
Night Gallery oh that was Stephen King's
right no that's true oh and then there
was after the toilets okay
and then he wrote the story for
something that was produced in 1995
called the girl with the hungry eyes and
I'm something that also a short called
Mariana that was just made in 2011 he's
credited for that's interesting yeah
it's fascinating yeah I mean that's a
lot of mileage for one story yeah you
know three three movies so some people
say that it's it's one of the best witch
stories are written and it's the
professor discovers his wife does magic
that's the one yeah yeah although I
think there's a lot of animation from
different sources something it was in
the New York Times today relevant to
Shakespeare and apparently these
Shakespeare guys are all really excited
they've used the software that was
developed for teachers to look for
students cheating Oh works to see well
where was she
drawing from it so there I didn't get
the whole story I ran out of time to
finish it but the same way that if
somebody said word of I mean it's a new
tool yeah yeah right yeah it's
plagiarism software but I mean but
nothing yeah Shakespeare was plagiarize
but you can go back maybe
sort of duomo starting from our in this
discarded transcript that would never
publish from by others yeah i got like a
turn of phrase to if you imagine if you
took some of these books and you ran
them through that something would come
on yeah so after that's that's a good
that's a good segue into talking about
like so what are what are his influence
as I mentioned Lovecraft but he read a
lot you know you know father and the
grim ouster are being drawn from you
know farmers this northern barbarian
clearly he's like a Viking as a matter
of fact there is one story where they
wind up in earth and because there's
like a you know one of them one of the
Wizards and then gobble of the seven
eyes ends up putting them into an
alternate universe which is earth and
five foot is Viking and great great
Mouser is from if I remember right from
the tire which is one of the Phoenician
cities you know so he's a little canine
you know swarthy guy shifty from the big
city and far furred as and then he he
draws on a lot of sources to try to
leave all these things together
Howard well that's something interest
and so Howard starts going in right but
Howard doesn't finish Conan I don't know
if Lieber actually wrote on a Conan
stories there were quite a few other
Tarzan stuff yeah yeah
although sort of somebody else would
talk about Phillip was a farmer right he
does that and he also does a Doc Savage
story so I guess there's there's some
characters that are kind of fair game
they become like like you know what
would you call it like public domain in
a certain way I mean Howard is is around
the same time
I think he gets if I remember right I
want to say he gets started like in the
30s I could be wrong about that though
that's some people are going to talk
about later on down the line because
it's such a big big hit again somebody
else who I read a lot of as a kid too
but with the Conan stories quite a few
of them are not by Howard there by like
Lynn Carter you know Lieber might have
written some liebhard also contributed
to the Cthulhu Mythos stuff there were a
lot of people you know getting into that
game after Lovecraft died so like you
know we've talked about during Wisconsin
I'm just I'm just thinking to that genre
the sorcerer yeah a merit yeah Howard
Weaver and Lynn Carver then we're all
writing within that genre close together
it's like it was a wave yeah and so what
what brought that about you know or what
what spurred that you know because we
have like kind of action you had a lot
of action stories before that right but
not not people like going at each other
specifically with swords in ancient /
medieval times you know usually set in
like made-up universes not that set here
or if they were they were like way back
when Atlantis existed you know that sort
of sort of business yeah I mean is in a
way the sorcery part is kind of like so
in science fiction right you've got like
lasers and technology that can do all
sorts of things the sorcery could be
just like that you know who one of the
people that we've read said you know to
sufficiently undeveloped society any
sort of technology appears to be magic
yeah there yeah yeah I think I'm
actually gonna turn it to a law or
something all right and so you get the
sense that and some of the swords and
sorcery stuff the sorcery stuff could
just as well be sci-fi stuff it's just
series okay
she wrote a series yeah yeah which the
source the source or circuit piece is
paranormal yeah mental powers yeah
they're all of their powers it's
paranormal psychic powers yeah and
there's sometimes connections like the
horror genre coming in too you know I
mean in a way I mean we talked about
these is like very distinct Johansson's
but if you think about the pulse of the
time they had different vents like some
were much more into you know sci-fi hard
sci-fi right don't bother me with that
that you know other stuff but I mean the
pulps encompassed a lot more than just
those speculative fiction genres they
are also like the true crime stuff which
a lot of which was frankly quite just
pornographic you know this is sort of
like a Spectre yes
that's kind of a spectrum of like I know
this is way something this is like we
talked about CL more and the fact that
her mom did not want her to write
science fiction or even read this month
because it was probably on the same
shelf as like you know true crime and
detective stuff you know and even even
the the artwork for her fantasy or
science fiction was pretty racy too you
know I think at the time because they
were trying to sell self copies so so
and Libra kind of Libra fits into that
very well I remember so when I was
reading the very first story again like
within just a few pages there's there's
there's a description of essentially a
sex act taking place
some some foreplay but it's written in
such a way that if you weren't really
paying attention of what's being said
you wouldn't catch it because Lieber is
that good of a writer he certainly snuck
this in so that's let's talk about his
world and in world building he you know
he's got this place and he calls it new
hun and it's a play on words
sort of like era one you know is nowhere
what is it backwards no new hotness is
it's not know where it's no one right
yeah no never took place so sort of like
instead of being utopia not a place
right place that doesn't exist it would
be uchronia
i guess you would say in greek a time
that never existed but he devotes a lot
of thought to telling us about this
world I mean even down to like this is
you know this is the sequence of days
each day is like named after a different
thing each month each year he tells us
about the landscape you know how trading
works the city itself where most of the
action takes place like Mars is this
very old city and he talks about certain
streets as being particularly important
and there's guilds like there's a
thief's guild and an Assassin's Guild
which is part of the I think the
Brotherhood of the Bravo's there's a
grain sellers guild you know merchants
then they they control a lot and it's a
city that is just old as dirt literally
it's it's been around longer than anyone
can remember it's even got its own gods
who nobody prays to and they just hope
that they won't come out I'll talk more
about that when we get to the guide
section and and there's like always
people on the make there and and and
lead Lieber is really good at describing
not just these two guys but everyone
else in the city and what their motives
are
their way of life is and what they're
trying to do and then he adds in you
know there's there's other people's so
there's like these people called the
mingles who of course are the Mongols
and they ride on the steeps and they
also sail and ships and and there can't
quiet and but good good companions and
then all sorts of other people and and
so he develops an entire world where he
never tells us exactly where things are
he's not like talking we're like talking
to make maps and write out the languages
and stuff like that it's almost like
he's making it up as he goes along but
it all fits together so you know to use
the classification that we talked about
before like Tolkien being the architect
and george RR martin being the gardener
I think Lieber would be more of a
gardener but I think he's probably a
better gardener than george RR martin
you know you maybe keeps things a bit
more more tidy or something i don't know
those of you who've read on water what
do you guys think on that who've read
both authors i really have much deeper
Martin is a gardener that's a good way
to put it yeah he's got this line I just
gonna put a seed there and water it and
see what but it's more like he's just
like you know combined like those those
big things of like yeah and they're
basically weeds right so you just like
cast the whole thing out there and see
what comes up you know whatever strong
is just gonna survive well so I mean
that's actually a good point if you're
for doing things in an architect kind of
way like you know Frank Herbert with Tim
too is a kind
detective you've got a lot of your you
know where things are going right you
could like you can actually like lay out
like a weekly schedule okay so this you
know this is when this thing happens and
I need to write about that but if you're
a gardener on the one hand you also
gotta wait for inspiration right I don't
know if I can write this character at
this time I don't know what they're
gonna do you know you don't have the
master plan but then you also have to
like figure out as you go along what the
hell are they doing and and who's doing
what to who and then you have to like
make sure you keep track of it too so
you don't have any not potholes but
inconsistencies right
Lieber doesn't seem to have too much
trouble with that I don't know a lot of
people pointing out inconsistencies with
these various stories so he must have
been quite good at keeping track of all
this stuff but it's a it's a really well
worked out world it's essentially you
know early medieval mixed together with
late antiquity there's a lot of things
that I think if you if you've studied
history you can easily recognize as just
sort of gussied up then of course
there's the magical aspect magic does
exist in this world the gods do exist
although none of the gods are actually
very powerful I like you know the way
that we tend to think about God because
there are some connections between the
Targaryen and the other houses that you
don't see the significance of it for
three more books yeah but he obviously
knew well he's a great example though
because he thought it was only gonna be
three books to start with start right
and and you notice the books keep
getting longer and longer and longer so
you know when he gets to the seventh
book as some people have actually sent
to that now it's supposed to turn into a
book series who knows okay
we're waiting us well then it's been
announced that it's coming really that's
like that big to look every Alexa
there's this is this is three books and
it is about 500 pages 496 so that is I
suppose some of it probably depends on
like the conditions under which people
number of people yeah grown into more
books I mean if you think about it
because you know the stuff that we write
on this becomes so much more efficient
it's easier to do that I suppose you
know yeah that's a typewriter instead of
rags but gets bigger yeah more
characters right or subplots you're
building all this and now you better
pull all these cars bureaus complicated
right yeah more there's more levels so
you're writing to cover all those levels
that's what I'm saying is so what what
is it like a desire with them the writer
that they date they're like a compulsion
I need to like follow out these threads
you know because we have some writers
that we've talked about who just keep on
hammering away you know at their third
world like an Macao
for example you know it helps too if you
got like the practice to come in and
take it over like she did with her son
to do that yeah Riley did that yeah
Herrmann did it a lot earlier yes
because you know he's only he's only
like four or five books in before I
think it's kid starts helping about
whereas McCaffrey is you know over a
dozen books and I think before he's he's
getting involved nobody hurt son oh yeah
yeah so I but is there is that I mean is
this something about a writer maybe that
this could be an interesting
philosophical theme when you become an
author does your world and your
characters start to take take and draw
you in and hire you to finish them out I
think it's that desire it needs the
designers flora to build the world and
explore it because if you're going to
build a world that's a lot of details
yeah yeah you're really gonna build a
world that's a lot of detail a lot of
interest and yeah if somebody is that
into the detail yeah that could be a big
piece of it I think too late when you
think of things like the Star Trek
universe
yeah when when worlds and universes and
things like that are built yeah there
becomes a point at which I mean look at
how we're talking about Martin like come
on they kind of belong you know family
yeah we're all a part of that world too
and so you know - there's like almost
like a compelling force that comes from
the readers and the fans asking for more
great and so there's this world that you
know I mean you see that with mystery
characters I think because he didn't
want to write anymore
well Herbert - with Timmy anymore
hands just assisted yeah I wonder I mean
if you're an author you could tell the
fan I'm not going to do any more right
what can they do to you well I think
that's suppose there's a mystery but I
mean now it's going to the point where
like each movie that comes out they've
already got like built-in things so that
they can have the sequel to it and
you're like I know this person isn't
really dead you know at the end of the
movie we'll see their hand come out or
something like that yeah yeah today you
know I think when it comes to the first
theme is the swords and sorcery what
what is that I think we've kind of
talked through that already alright so
let's start about friendship these guys
like I'd mentioned are sort of like you
know the archetype of like the the good
friends like Gilgamesh and what is it
Anke no that's that's one of the guys
I'm Keita yeah
or you know some of the other companions
throughout time these guys get called
the Twain and it's hinted at that
there's like a metaphysical basis to
this that they exist in different worlds
together
it begins with them separate you know
five hurt is up north and he's trying to
get out of it he wants to get to
civilization and get away from his mom
and the other
you know people of his clan and the
Mauser is studying with this wizard
there's a whole sort of origin story
then they wind up in the lock Mar
together and they they wind up both
trying to rob the same thieves there's
great passage where they're both
disguised as pillars and the thieves are
walking past and one pillar sees the
other pillar move and they they're like
well you know I guess we'll rob them
together so they prey on these these
thieves and then everything gets kids
going after that and they do have you
know some each of them has a love
interest at the start that gets them to
the LAN kamar but both of them die and
so these two guys are together and they
become like the best of friends there is
a time when they part from each other
and they get ticked off with each other
so the monster starts working for a
extortioner and Pfeiffer has a religious
conversion and starts working for this
this almost senile priest who who is the
one single priest of Isaac
I think it's Isaac of the jug that might
be mixing it up but the rest of the time
they're always together and sometimes
they you know they get become rivals or
they get in fights but they're always
there for each other and so I thought
one of the things that could be
interesting to talk about there's this
classic discussion of friendship in in
Aristotle and types of friendship and
Aristotle says that you know it's okay
to have different kinds of friends some
of our friends are not very close there
they're the useful and maybe we're
useful to them and they're useful to us
these are you know maybe your neighbors
that invite you over for a barbecue and
you borrow their their lawnmower
you know they clean your drive or stuff
like that you can you can rely on them
when you're going to like make sure you
know that nobody's gonna break into your
house but frankly you're not really that
close to them and there may be things
about them that you're not into it
this would be a lot of people at work I
think too and then there's the
pleasurable there's there's people that
were friends with because we enjoy their
company or we do fun things together
like maybe we play a sport with them or
you know they're they're the funny
person or and a lot of cases where we
like people who are attractive to be
around or the person who can actually
play a musical instrument or something
like that we get pleasure from it well
that's good and so I give you some
examples here like eating food together
right
a lot of sexual relations are probably
like that and then Aristotle talks about
a different kind of friendship that's
much more rare as a matter of fact some
people may not be capable of this
everybody's capable of a friendship in
terms of it useful or in terms of the
pleasurable but only good people or
people who are striving for goodness are
capable of the friendship of the noble
or the fine
and I think that you know actually
Aristotle doesn't talk about this very
much but if you think about like a
marriage right a marriage might actually
start out in something where it's a
friendship of the useful you know we
talked about marriages of convenience or
it might be pleasurable and then as
intimacy grows and the people get to
know each other and maybe in some cases
actually have to turn into good people
they're capable of having a much deeper
kind of friendship and non erotic
friendships can become deep in that
sense as well and so the question then
is what kind of friendship do these guys
have and a lot of that depends on what
we make of their moral character which
is another topic that I wanted to to get
into but I want him to talk first about
the notion of friendship itself and you
know another thing that was brought up
quite a bit in the ancient world and I
think it's a live issue today
you know what is the value of friendship
do we you know we all want to say 200
million friends right but why do we want
to be one friends just for the useful or
just for the pleasurable or do we you
know with the the nobler the fine you
know the person for who they are you
appreciate them for who they are rather
than just the fact that they can make
you smile or you know get your tickets
to something or whatever commitment yeah
very true and you can only have in your
life so many people at that level yeah
because that's the level where your
friend gets cancer and you bring them
meals every day that's that's a big test
yeah you know that's for know somebody
that you're so connected to and they
would do the same for you
yeah but the commitment to that
psychologically you can't have that many
people at that level yeah and stay sane
well you can't have that many people
period because there's not enough time
you can't you cannot have that kind of
level of commitment except to just a few
people yeah I mean we see something
where it can be widened a little bit
with like you know religious communities
right or other intentional communities
even that is tough yeah I mean when you
read monastic literature the monks
sometimes like don't like each other and
they you know try to screw each other
over hurtful tricks on each other nuns
to do that sort of thing to each other
but it happens interestingly like across
the entire religious spectrum not just
Christians but Buddhists Hindus you know
because the literature for them and they
all have problems so you know I was seen
actually trying to have something like
that with his his friends an intentional
community where they are like we're all
going to study you know rhetoric
philosophy history we're gonna live
together like it's sort of like a
kommune he said of work good a lot of
the time
then there's their Sephora listen we're
in that situation as opposed to choosing
a friendship I mean you're choosing yeah
- and yeah you said somebody you're
really really attracted to you have a
lot in common with you're really you're
drawn to that and then you know the
benefits are that you know you it helps
with your loneliness that helps you live
longer you've got somebody and always go
you guys so they're always there you
know that person there's somebody always
there and then you're never gonna be
alone that's that's the commitment as
opposed to being in the you know big
community you're kind of stuck there and
and you know you're gonna have
friendships but not not that kind of
commitment like you said that you're
there
yeah lots of people useful yeah you can
have a lot of those connections and that
spreads in the small episode here are
think about like how many friends how
many friends you can have anymore
the person might call three o'clock that
morning because you just haven't got
awful dream I mean that's the person
that's you you know there's a branch
renoble yeah yeah do you call your
friends no I don't that's really but
yeah you know Aaron's level one of the
other things that he says about friends
is he says it's in in a later party with
Nicomachean ethics that they they share
in each other's joys and they share in
each other sorrows or pains or griefs
you know and that's exactly what you're
talking about
you you find out who your real friends
are when everything goes to crap you
know and it's interesting one of the one
of the Psalms I forget which one it is
it's fairly early on because I say
Thomas Aquinas wrote a commentary on
that one he died before he finished
Psalm 54 so I know it's got to be in the
first 50 or so it's about like it's what
this lament about how this guy was
really really close to his friend and
his friends screwed him over
you know his friend wasn't there for him
just when he needed Oh his rings yeah I
mean who needs friends like those
translation you're right yeah they feel
affection yeah and and it's a different
motivation you're you're friends with
somebody because they're pleasurable so
when they stop being pleasurable then
the friendship come can die unless
you're the guilty sort you just keep
them around forever and Aristotle
actually says you know useful
friendships when they're no longer
useful it's actually good for you to let
it go you know you shouldn't try to like
make it last forever and I think one of
the big problems that people get into
especially young people these days is
this notion that if I make friends with
somebody I have to be friends with them
forever you know and not let you know
wouldn't people change let things die
but far in the great monster they they
really have found companions in each
other another another thing so let's
talk about this this are they good
people they are rose they prey on the
thieves so that I think there's maybe
some justification right so like except
that they don't give just that whole
idea of your basic you're kind of not a
good person but you but you still carry
out these you know these things where
even if it's over your gratification but
you still bottom line you're not going
to go out and do something horrible like
murder and think that you maybe there
are some limits for them yeah but they
are they are perfectly willing to if
somebody gets a fight with them kill
them they do steal from merchants and an
awful lot there's a lot of things like
you know they don't have horses that
guys get horses we're taking those
horses you know and they steal valuable
items to pretty routinely from from you
know rich merchants and people like that
any code of honor and
hey if you're stealing for rich
merchants is there an undercurrent of
yeah they're not they got rich because
they're not totally honest well nobody's
there nobody who's richest people
anyways enough yeah and I mean they in a
way they are job creators because when
they have money they spend it on like
buying things for you know women that
they're involved with getting drunk
fancy food you know trinkets and stuff
like that as a matter of fact there's
some discussion in there between
Pfeiffer to the Great Mouse or at one
point like in the third book why why if
we make so much money don't we have any
money rocford is like well you spend it
on this and the great Mouser is well you
spend it on this so don't think I'm
married to couple you know why is there
no money in the bank well you know you
spent it on this there's there like that
so I mean they are you know you could
say they are benefiting the economy
right and they don't prey on the poor
generally yeah yeah even more so even
more so they only prey on them they have
this code we have some quarterback they
have a circuit but now prey on innocent
so it's sort of like there's there's
lines right and so long as you don't go
outside of those lines you're not going
to be subject to the rogue or the
vampire whoever going after your stuff
but once you've gone past that now
you're fair game
is that the idea well it's like they
only prey on evil evil yeah people who
that's that's who they prey on they
don't prey on innocent blood
they don't take it a little more
vigilante sort of things like their
variety has
feed I'm going to feed on somebody who
doesn't contribute to this world very
well you know if you think about what we
value is character traits in people so
these guys are both generous
they're both loyal you know to people
that that don't cross them and they're
loyal to each other and they're loyal to
their their their women that they're
involved with but I'll find an at-at
first this girl that he gets pregnant
he's a child behind but everybody else
he is one of their characters what are
the other characteristics you can't say
that they're just because they are doing
unjust things they're fairly temperate I
mean they get drunk every once in a
while but they're not like raging drunks
yeah I mean so they would be the kind of
people that somebody like Aristotle
would say they're not virtuous but they
have their like they have a tendency
towards virtue you know or Cicero let's
say that they have the outlines of
virtue or vestiges of virtue within them
and we can recognize that and see that
is that's good
but I think that you know as readers
it's very easy for us and this happens I
think a lot in TV shows and other
stories as well for us to say well I
like this character even though there if
I really think about it they're not a
morally good person I really do like
them and I want them to succeed against
whoever they're they're facing who might
have a more just claim to you know be in
charge haven't have money or things like
that but we've me what is it about these
the road that we we get drawn in I mean
think about like Indiana Jones right we
root for an Indiana Jones he's not a
good guy you know he seduced you know
what's what's her name at one time
and he you know he basically keeps his
hands off his students but he's
perfectly willing to like you know go in
and take you know ancient artifacts out
of places you might be doing it to try
to save them from other people who are
going to sell them but he's put one play
faster this but we look we're like he's
a great guy you know I'd like to be like
him or I hope he wins or things like
that and I think we do the same thing
with these guys so you know what's
what's behind that is it that you know
maybe telling a story gets us out of the
moral frame of mind er oh we loved it
when he was the one who not like yeah
that's amazing yeah it's fine yeah
rules parameters sometimes you know you
just want a sort of pretty exerciser
test the limits or reset the limits or
whatever they may be so you say well
this might be a interesting episode
because yeah so you do something it's an
event I see I think that's I think the
ethics have become over time more and
more relativistic yeah it's relative
mm-hmm what is good how far can you go
in some ways that it is that way and in
other ways it's more puritanical you
know like a viewer to write some of the
stuff that we've been reading if you
were to write it today
given how some of the characters arraign
you know sort of orient themselves in
terms of like how they treat people of
different genders or races
you and just get torn apart you know on
Twitter and all these things this person
I really I mean thought the right would
be like oh we should read these books
you know the far right but everyone else
will be going after you so I think in
some respects there's there's less play
for some things you know I mean think
about like than me to move it you know
people who get swept up in that and I
think you know in many ways it's a good
thing that's happening but people get
swept up in it now they can't have a
career at all and we have to like take
them out of movies and stuff like that
we're making these very strong aesthetic
judgments on moral grounds you know that
maybe you know 10 years from now people
are gonna look at us and they're gonna
be like well that was an interesting
episode
yeah so they're saying no that's not
what it is this because it's been since
the dawn of civilization women have been
there and if there's a little overkill
right now so sad too bad because it's
correcting you know yeah I'm not
complaining no I know I'm not and I'm
not and I'm doing em in general not or
not to think but I mean that's I think
what's happening is that if you'd like
to say we're coming back from a tear
when the pendulum swings so far down it
goes maybe the other way or it equalizes
right now swing in the other way and
then before equal Isis just because it
you think it will come back and equalize
the erasure is an interesting concept
though because there's morally corrupt
people in Reno
Aereo society if there is a society
there's moral corruption and there's a
power dynamic there is an oppressed
class and that's just always been the
case but it's fascinating that people
are being literally you know digitized
out of scenes and film the same way that
they did I mean when I lived in New York
City and the towers came down and then
suddenly your
that were set to come out right there
was this collective like we must protect
people from the potential psychological
trauma she was talking and they sure I
think it was Superman and he was just
supposed to be her spine mater's yeah
yeah and you were just say you can't do
that like that was my skyline for 20
years like you don't just remove them
yeah
there is one movie where they they they
FEMA ties that and it wasn't a great
movie but I like that about the movie
was called I think the 25th hour had
Edward Norton in it oh right yeah Pass
yeah sort of like a stumble almost human
humanity tends towards black what yeah
tends towards simple rules it's got to
be this way or it's got to be that like
good bad the living is LITTLEST but
looking in the grave as hard as fluid
steadily it's hard for most people most
people don't live in the grip these guys
are definitely I mean great mouth if you
always need answers you're never gonna
want to be you know in a non dual
situation but in that Gray's you can
just find I mean you just can experience
so much more you learn so much more but
it is so difficult for most people a lot
of people it is yes and you know because
you think there's right wrong well okay
so it's wrong it's wrong to rob a bank
but isn't wrong for that person who
wants that money it's right for him so I
mean if you start looking at all of
these things from all these different
perspectives pretty soon you can be like
yikes it looks like then there's Rob
Lowe it was wrong yeah but if you still
offer bread to feed your sister's
children right it wasn't wrong for him
you know like what you when you start to
look at a non dual situation like talk
about like there's two ways things could
be gray like that one is like you'll so
you got black over here and white over
here and then like you know gray in the
middle like when they're kids and we had
to do all those color things remember in
our class the other way is with like
what they call cherish current which is
where you've got like things still are
black and white but the black and the
white are like so closely bound up with
that they look great and I think a lot
of things really are gray like that
where we we can't make a decision unless
we're actually in the situation because
then we're close enough where we can see
uh-huh
here's the white part here's the black
part you know well that has to do with
consequences and whether you intend the
consequences or not so no it's Thomas
Thomas Aquinas Abelard talks about the
intention of an act as is entirely what
makes it right so he would also say I
mean there could be some things where
the consequences turned out not good but
you didn't intend those consequences you
intended something that brought about
those consequences but you weren't
intending that like I mean a lot of the
mistakes that we make well you know a
think about traffic right you you intend
just to like stop your car from skidding
you had no you no intention of like
swerving off the road hitting that
person but that was the consequence and
like if you had a better view of what
was going on you probably could have
foreseen that that was going to happen
but in the situation you couldn't
actually well you see the regulation
because yeah well sometimes good nice
yeah there are so many variables yeah
yeah the unintended consequences yeah
can be devastating
you don't think far enough ahead if you
don't take it on account all the
different variables that are in play
yeah and there's a really bad problem as
a process issue that there's no feedback
point when things are written their life
and it's then that goes back to the
black and white so we wrote it we must
follow it we can't change it
there's a good distinction that gets
made today between you know it's a
software thing
there's something as a feature or a bug
right some government decisions
unintended consequences happen and they
seem to be like bugs others it's almost
like it's set up you know if you think
about like trying to use example try to
use the healthcare exchange right it
seems almost as if the system is set up
to make it difficult for people to
navigate through it and I don't you know
I'm not a conspiracy theorist or
anything like that but it strikes me
that a government that wants to save
money could very easily decide to do
things hey you know with you know they
are intending that that consequence I
think in a lot of cases well if you do
things like that
is you get into things that are created
because of political negotiation right
so in order to solve oh yeah that makes
sense first party is in interest you get
something that's far more complicated
than it needs to be yeah yeah that's
what happened with ACA the convent the
negotiations that happened created far
more complexity than was originally
intended yeah let me let me go back to
the gender relations cuz that was one of
the things I wanted to talk about so
Lieber is writing at a time that we
don't think it was particularly alight
right early on but this is from this is
from blog post advanced readings in D&D
fritz leiber
by Mordecai Cano de I think he's right
about this he says lead the light or
lever laggers ladies are generally on
the positive end of the spectrum they're
defined by their roles as romantic foils
but they're not negative roles they have
agency typically in service to either
narrative Fiat or the agenda of the
antagonists they're almost always weird
he says by way of example here the women
in question are the invisible nude
goblins who live on the mountain they
reveal themselves to great Mouser and
fathered by covering themselves in paint
or in lace pinup sure but now
they aren't even the weirdest ones for a
while gray mousers involved with an
albino where rat and Pfeiffer dates of
ghoul whose flesh and organs are
transparent leaving only her skeleton
visible eventually and this is this
happens really late in the game offered
and the great Mouser settle down with
two female counterparts sip and offer it
as this guy says these are the best of
libras women as the lank marsh stories
of all sodas characters and he's right
about that because that last book and
they're actually there in the the second
last book to they actually become main
characters which is interesting and say
you look at lemur he's writing this
towards the end of his life and what was
going on with his thought about this
well you know he always had female
characters who who were had a lot of
agency the woman who fathered winds up
being involved with at the very start I
forget her name right now she you know
she's really on the same level as father
unfortunately she dies right away Lana
that's right
and when interestingly when of Lana and
the great mahou sirs fiance died because
the thief guild has a sorcerer who like
he has these things come in and
strangled them and then the place
collapses they they don't really have
anything to do with women for a long
time they they're so bereaved over the
loss of their their lungs they both
attend and settle down with that for a
long time that's just them on their own
that changes later out of course but I
think it's kind of an interesting point
you know there are a lot of I mean quite
frankly just misogynist
portrayals of women you know one of the
one of the extremely Robert Howard is
not very good with that sort of thing
yeah I'll say and you know I don't
remember who wrote the gore series but
those are really really over the top do
you remember the name of Michael
Moorcock actually thought those gore
books should be put like in drugstores
they should be put on the same like
hidden rack as pornography let's stop
with a bit of plot yeah yeah so yeah
it's kind of an interesting point the
last thing I wanted to talk about this
whole room the you can we call it a
religious system because system implies
that there's some sort of order to
religion in in Locke mark instead you've
got well it knew huh you've got all this
stuff going on all these different cults
all these different gods coming into
existence Lieber actually says most of
them start as human beings who something
happens to them and then people start
worshipping them and through the act of
worship they acquire something some
power and the more worshipers you have
the more power you have but even the
most strongly worshipped gods don't have
enough power to overpower the other gods
although they sometimes try and within
lock bar itself there's like a whole
pecking order you know you start out at
this this gate and as you make your way
up the street you become more and more
important and you might actually like
rent or buy out one of the temples of
one of the gods who fell on hard times
they're like well hell we buy people's
foreclosed houses you know that's
exactly what's so think it was like a
religious marketplace right which in
religious studies they actually do use
that
metaphor like market share to talk about
denominations and it works here over
time
yeah other approaches well some of them
were similar already right few they're
only you know Yanis happens a lot yeah I
mean Greeks are doing that they picked
up holidays that the Romans had that was
that was very good meat yeah because you
have a day off yeah you know there's
also one with religious sites to so like
you know I've been reading beads history
of the English church and people and in
it he talks about you know the the
Romans and the Britons and the Saxons
coming in and all that and when the
church comes in with this this guy
Augustine
not not the Augustine that we think
about Augustine of Hippo but another
Augustine there's a deliberate decision
and it's in one of the letters of one of
the Gregory's it might be great read the
great and he says don't knock the
temples down because that's he doesn't
say it like this but I'm gonna
paraphrase that's good real estate you
know and plus people are used to going
there already so you know you can
rededicate it you know Syracuse in
Sicily yeah yeah the very base of it is
is a worship site from about 5,000
Wow on top of that was built a Greek
temple okay and now it's a Catholic
cathedral yeah but the Greek pillars are
still in the church yeah yeah yeah
everything is still there yeah so there
the gods there's a whole bunch of them
and you know when we think about like
polytheism right we often think about
how there's a pantheon of the gods and
you know like this one does this this
one does that it's not even remotely
organized like that in neon and a lot
more it's sort of like whatever your God
can like take over and get away with you
know or whatever they want to that's
that's what they do and so they try to
get supporters and the guys play a you
know important roles there's other
things that are not gods but our powers
necessity chants death Death himself
shows up in some of the stories and says
you you know father the great master you
do great work for me you know there's
things like that going on and and it's
kind of funny I think he's kind of
spoofing religion in a lot of cases
there is also one set of gods who had
mentioned a little bit earlier then
these are very serious these are the
gods on blank mark very ancient they
saved the day in one of the other than
the novel
is the one word we're just talking about
you know great Mouser actually does
become a rat and there's like a
conspiracy of grants to take over the
gods come out of there their temple and
and you know save the day but you don't
want to wake up the gods of Langhorne
and as a matter of fact if you get too
uppity as like a new God the Geisel
ain't marble we'll take care of you and
kill all your priests and you know
you'll just disappear so you don't want
to you know how to mess with that
there's even interesting things like
early on in the series the Thieves Guild
they you know they have all these old
skulls which are the the disembodied
consciousness is essentially the gods of
their old rulers of the Thieves Guild
the the guy in charge and the new
thieves they're all like that's all
superstition that's BS we don't believe
in any of that crap well the guys
actually kind of take care of sorry and
that may start worship so it's a you
know he really weaves it in there in an
interesting way
fathered well father does believe in two
guns Isaac of the jogger who he becomes
the acolyte of and the other God from
his his ancestral homeland and there's
another guy who's interested in the
great Mouser but they don't they're not
you know other than the period were
fathered himself is an athlet they're
not very devout and their gods don't
have much pull at all oh so they can't
do much of anything for them that's kind
of a funny you know little things but a
lot of people are very invested in that
world in in worship as a matter of fact
I'll also mention this the great Bowser
I mentioned that Pfeiffer did the great
masters split apart at that point so the
great master becomes an extortioner he
kept he becomes an extortioner for a guy
who specializes in extorting
religious cults and their practitioners
and eventually that guy converts that
becomes a devotee of Isaac of the jug
and he so extorted everybody else yeah
because he's not gonna stop making money
and he figures that way he's doing doing
a good job for for his gun and so
there's a lot of sort of moral
compromises that people can get where
their values seem you know a little bit
strange when it comes to religion but
it's 22 there's also a goddess in one of
the stories who reestablishes her
worship by having her crows come in and
steal all of the the jewels and pecked
the faces of these these women who are
not worshiping her as they they ought to
be and tries to get you know her her
things started although father the great
master the feeder so I think that's kind
of an interesting theme I don't quite
know what to make of this myself but it
is an important part of their their girl
what should we call it
it's not even polytheism because
polytheism implies some sort of
structure or order you know it but it
strikes me as mockery of what we
experience and realize in terms of in
denominations oh yeah surprisingly yeah
Wesley with the Methodist Church the
different denominations yeah sniff the
organism yeah there's somebody at the
head of those Buddha's and other people
make more of them yeah then they ever
intended to be and sometimes I think one
is some in various altars that they're
taking shots at how American
denomination just American know
worldwide just how we if you
humanity yeah approaches religion I mean
it's kind of got the market cornered
though if you think about religious
history in terms of just like the sheer
like plethora not only HS that we have
in part because we didn't have an
official church you know like so i mean
if you're in germany there are lots of
different religious people right but the
three main denominations were Catholic
Lutheran and Reformed yeah so yeah yeah
specifically Protestant pressure because
I mean if you take all the earlier
churches pre Protestant churches you
know you've got a bunch of different
Orthodox churches but they're all part
of one communion you've got the Roman
with a bunch of different rights all
part of one communion and then you've
got about seven or eight other smaller
further east churches like the Coptic
this you know very serious ones they are
Manian Church the Ethiopian Church and
that's that's pretty much yeah that
covers like almost everybody and then
you've got over 10,000 different
Protestant denominations so it's really
at one side there seems to be state of
mind in Protestantism well we disagree
well just form another church yeah they
caught one of the neighbors called it
the Protestant principle you know
disagree okay
a place I've taught some really do
classes for example I use is Amish men
one particularly Amish you can find so
many different groups within the Amish
and frequently they broke off because
they didn't like that they didn't think
that bonnet was fruitless yeah or that
type of dress was referred to modern to
fancy
and they would split to a different
group and we're seeing it today in
mainline churches over gender issues
yeah yeah I mean once you've established
the thing that if you don't like it you
can split it's harder to hold people in
there if there's one religion that we're
here it's splitting was that high oh we
have a rule although they haven't been
around that long so but they actually
rule that says you have to work out your
differences you don't get to split off
okay they're the only religion that has
that principle well you've got all these
different rights to even within the
Catholic Church yeah so that a lot of
some diversity and I mean the thing is
within the Catholic Church you get a lot
of arguments from one side or the other
about just by that how do you do the
liturgy what songs should there be and
you know everyone everyone's it sort of
like everybody's stuck in the same big
bag and you have to fight it out but
nobody ever really wins it's totally
different than what's going on in these
stories that's more like the Protestants
you know certainly and not just the
Protestant spectrum you know it's not
the more sedate stuff it's sort of like
imagine all of the different
denominations that only have a few
believers are all sort of battling it
out you know the ones that are newer and
more willing to scrap with each other I
guess
sort is it sorcery no religion no
concept the discrepant we're trying to
get worship this first time right well
nobody means it the basic tenets of
going back to Christian right back to
the Christ what's it with any of that
got to do with the basic teaching
principles of which all this was
supposedly found it out yeah well much
much of that much of that disparity has
to somebody saying some interpretation
we've gotten it wrong over the years we
who straight wrote real teaching we need
to get back to where yeah that's the
thing though when we when we think about
religion because we were from you know
the era that we are we tend to think
okay Christianity that's the paradigm
but you know many of the religions that
have been practiced it wasn't quite so
so elevated was well literally it was in
Landon's don't with DES I give so that
you give something back to me I mean
sacrificed so you give me some good
crops or you know a beautiful
you know spouse or prosperity
I prayed therefore I get this back yeah
that's true yeah so so maybe he's making
fun of that no we're just playing around
with the idea or you know maybe he's
just taking stuff from many things or in
the ancient world
sand rises I mean Herbert I mean this is
like an Antipodes from Herbert you know
with Herbert religion really is
important now that he's he's not a
believer himself and you know he has
yeah it has the potential like totally
changed the universe and its political
structure these guys don't you know they
don't really change anything
catholic bible and everything is based
on and controlling the population yeah
well I am an ecumenical project of
bringing everybody back out of the same
page trying to overcome diversity
there's nothing I mean the key there is
every once in a while like a guy who
gets uppity and says like I'm gonna be
da one God but that never works in this
book so yeah well we're at about 8:30 so
we should wrap it up thanks for another
great discussion
[Music]
you